have we met Nathan Brad I'm the new
English teacher
you live near here
yeah the old Biddle house
the Barrel House
I did hear the horrible story about the
boy who used to live there
you know I hear it's haunted
have you seen anything
strange happening there
no
not that I can think of
[Music]
some weird stuff has been happening
something's clearly wrong
would you do that man that's not cool
there's no such thing as a curse dude
that isn't real
[Music]
are you okay
this is all connected he's getting
revenge for what our parents did to him
oh my God we're murdered Napo babies
[Music]
it's obvious you know
we have no choice this ends no
it's time for them to learn the truth
come with me
oh my God we need to talk why does James
smell like watermelon Jolly Ranchers